i'm here today with my new friend riley
who's going to help us check out a new
website called dognition that for 60
bucks will help you assess your dog's
intelligence the basic premise here is
not so much that they're smart dogs and
dumb dogs although there's probably some
truth to that the idea is that different
dogs use different cognitive strategies
to help them solve problems so this was
based on research by brian hare who's a
cognitive neuroscientist at duke
university and we wanted to try to get a
sense of whether this can actually work
with regular people who aren't
scientists and
regular dogs like riley here so here we
go
do
okay so we have some results here from
dognition on riley and the test we did
with him unfortunately we couldn't get
through the complete battery of tests
because we didn't have access to the to
the website but based on the
things that we did do we have some
preliminary results suggesting that uh
riley is an independent problem solver
and that's because in the experiment
where his owner put a piece of food
under one cup and pointed to the other
cup riley said forget you ignored his
owner went to where he he knew the food
was so he relied on his own memory
instead of his owner with cupcake here
cupcake's a puppy and he had a tendency
to to wander off a little bit and get
distracted and different dogs apparently
do this differently some rely more on
their owners for
solving problems others prefer to just
solve it their own way so there you have
it riley is a free thinking canine